-Our first guest tonight
is the Governor of California.
Please welcome back to the show
Governor Gavin Newsom.
-It's great to be with you.
-Thank you so much.
Obviously, this is
an incredibly busy time for you.
We really appreciate
you making time for us.
You were in the studio
three months ago,
a very different world
than just three months ago.
-Yeah, isn't it amazing?
I mean,
I was not only in your studio,
I was here at the state capital,
announcing
a $6 billion budget surplus
in the state of California,
record job growth,
record reserves.
And I'm about to update
the budget
and talk about unprecedented
unemployment and deficits.
And every day,
I go in front of the press,
and I announce
the number of lives lost --
another 95 human beings
lost their lives
in the last 24 hours
here in California alone.
It's remarkable what a few
months -- how things can change.
-You were the first governor
to issue a stay-at-home order.
And I think, in these really
fractured political times,
people might forget
that no governor ever wants
to tell the people
in their state to stay at home.
That must have been
an incredibly hard decision.
Can you talk about
the difficulty in making it?
-Yeah.
It's a hard decision because --
just 'cause you say something
doesn't mean people
are gonna do something.
But all this happens
with the speed of trust.
And if you don't have
the trust of folks,
you're doing the right thing
for the right reasons,
things could fall apart.
What I was so humbled by,
so amazed by,
was how 40 million people --
I mean, this is the fifth
largest economy in the world --
it truly is a nation-state
in terms of the size and scale
and scope --
across every geographic
and political difference,
overwhelmingly abided
by the stay-at-home order
for at least the last 60 days.
The challenge
is we're now in a period
where people have cabin fever
and they're very,
very frustrated
and want to come back.
And so this is, I think,
the most challenging period
for all of us --
not just
for the folks in California,
but we were really,
really humbled
by how people took to heart
this crisis
and recognized their imperative
to do the right thing
as individuals
so that they can help
the state of California.
-Californians, justifiably so,
brag about their beaches.
We saw footage this past weekend
of a lot of people
crowding the beaches.
You just gave a press conference
where, I think specifically
in Orange County,
you reinforced the importance
of staying at home.
Is that --
That must be hard.
You mentioned cabin fever.
You know,
people want to be outside.
-No, I've spent
my entire political life
opening up beach access,
fighting for people's right
to their beach.
And this state --
it's one of the reasons
Horace Greeley said,
"Go West, young man, go West,"
in the 1850s.
It's our natural beauty --
an 1,100-mile coastline,
800 miles of pristine beaches,
none more beautiful
than down in Orange County,
one of the really
most magnificent,
bucolic parts of the world.
And so I hated to do it,
but I had to do it
on the basis
of the advice and counsel
from my public health directors.
They're all saying the only way
we can set this course back
to re-opening
with modifications, our economy,
is to see the kind
of concentration
that we saw on those beaches
over the weekend.
And so
we're going to do our best,
try to be collaborative
and cooperative.
Most of the beaches --
over 100 did everything right,
and the communities there
really met the moment.
But, unfortunately, people
were really eager to get out,
a little too much so
last weekend.
And so
I just want to slow that down,
decompress a little bit,
and then have a pathway
to reopen very quickly.
-You have announced
a four-phase plan to reopening.
One of the fears, of course,
is we've seen in countries
that have started to re-open
that there's an uptick in cases.
How strictly do you adhere
to this four-phase plan,
and how often during the day are
you checking in with the data
to back up the choices?
-Every single morning.
We're driven by data.
We're driven by health.
We're driven by evidence.
We're not ideological
about any of this.
You know, a lot of pressure
to quote, unquote,
"re-open the economy."
If that is the best public
health decision, I'll make it.
But it's not right now.
It would be devastating.
Just ask the folks in Singapore,
parts of China,
that island
off the coast of Japan
that's part of Japan,
where they had
all this progress,
and, literally, in a moment,
they unwound
all of that progress.
They ran the proverbial
90-yard dash.
We don't want to do that.
So our health directors --
not just our state folks,
but the local folks
will guide that.
And we're also guided by this --
a recognition
in a state as large as ours
that each jurisdiction's
a little bit different
than the other.
And so we're looking
at some regional variations,
regional constructs
that may allow
some parts of the state
to move a little bit sooner
than other parts.
-The last time we spoke,
we talked about the fact
that you have sued
the Trump administration
over 70 times.
There has been criticism from
both sides towards each other.
And yet, you've also praised
the federal government response
in the way
they've helped California.
Does -- To the point
that the President has actually
released a new campaign
with and both you and
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
saying nice things about him,
can we say that the relationship
is decent at this point?
-Well,
we've filed two new lawsuits
since we were last together,
and we will continue to fight
to protect our values,
and when it comes to diversity,
clean air, clean water,
the health of this state,
we will always stand
on principle and stand tall.
But, you know,
my mom taught me be polite,
and when someone --
you ask for help
and someone actually delivers,
you have to acknowledge it.
And so all I can talk to is
through the prism and the frame
of the state of California.
When I've called
the administration,
when I've called
the President directly,
not only
is he available and answers,
but he's also delivered
on a lot of the requests.
And so I can make it up --
I could try to avoid any kind
of non-partisan behavior
and just play hard in my lane
as a Democrat
and a tribal mind-set.
But we're in a crisis.
I'm trying to save
40 million Californians,
40 million Americans
that live in California.
And I don't care if
you're Democrat or Republican.
I care that you care
about your kids
and your community
and your loved ones,
and we're all in this together.
And so that's the spirit
we're bringing into this.
But it doesn't stop us
from having our points of
disagreement, I can assure you.